How about 10,000 people? 10,000 people are making a noise. It's about time,
village. With over
10,000 followers, I
'll show you the power to update the absolute ultimate maximum value.
[Music]
No. 1 1,77
Why do you have more followers? I don't know.
But if I have this much power,
I won't lose to anyone, so I'll rebuild the ad. It doesn't matter, I'll defeat it. It doesn't matter how many I
get, it doesn't matter how many I want to get. The
problem
is the problem.
One blow.
[Applause]
[Music] It
's just the limit.  I happened to be saved by Mitama-chan.
How can you do something like this, little girl? It
was just a matter of courage, but thanks to me, you
survived. You should be grateful. Well, you should be grateful, too.
As a believer in me, too.  I've become aware of it. I'm
not a believer.